so I love surprising people today I'm
surprising my barber Michael Rafa Tony
was out there last week is cutting my
hair and he says Pat I just signed a new
lease to get a new barbershop and he's
excited my stomach's gonna put this TV
all this stuff he says I want to put a
65 inch screen TV on the wall what do
you think about it said I don't know let
me think about it
so while we were thinking about it we
had Mario and everybody go get him a 65
inch screen TV he's in the front lobby
he's about to come and see it and know
that it's his gift let's his reaction
yeah so I'm like in the front hey Mike
anyways hey you told me you wanted to
put up a 65 inch screen TV yes in your
barber and your new barber shop yes so I
got it for you I'm excited for you man
I'm excited for you you're a class act
man you're more than just the barber to
me you're a friend we have very good
times together but I'm excited we opened
up a business now you got yourself a
brand new one so
thank you so anytime you got the whole
shebang you guys can watch The Godfather
you guys can do anything by the way
here's what's funny when you're in there
and he cuts your hair 9 out of 10 times
he's playing to Rocky movie so anyways
let me explain to why I did this for
Michael number one the guy is a great
guy
every time I'm with him he talks to me
about how it's raising a stepson and his
family and his wife how hard he's trying
to be a great citizen I sit there and I
just enjoy the conference I look forward
to getting a haircut from Michael but
let me take the other reason why I'm
doing this 45 million people have lost
jobs in America think about how many
small businesses have lost everything
they've had when a guy like Michael at a
time like this is risking his safe job
to go start a business
America needs that it's a form of being
patriotic to create a new business that
creates new jobs but he's putting his
entire life savings into it I have so
much respect for that and sometimes
people you know in your life that are
starting a business all they need is a
little encouragement you'd be amazed how
much of an impact you can make in
someone's life that's about to start a
business you may not need to buy them a
you know TV and spend whatever amount of
money you need to spend but maybe it's a
small little gesture something that
makes them know that you're encouraging
them so I'm sharing this video with you
hopefully you don't aspire to right
people to go out there and do this for
someone in your life don't do it just
for people that are immediate yes for
your kids for your mom for your dad for
your sibling but surprise somebody that
are not expecting anything from you and
share that with the world God knows we
need to see more videos like that then
it kind of videos we're seeing right now
on TV so having said that the best way
you can give Michael love is I want to
put his handle below go following give
them a bunch of encouragement for him to
start a new business and if you're in
the Plano area let him know you're
looking forward to going to get a
haircut from the guy he will be
somewhere in Plano Texas
having said that Michael a Prada buddy
love you cannot wait to see your dreams
become a reality
starting with this barbershop called
Rapa Tony's barbershop